hello everyone welcome to another tango
technique class at home i hope you are
doing fine
today will be very simple and it will be
the same for men and women we will go
back to basics because i would like to
give you a few exercises that will help
you improve the way you approach and the
way you embrace your partner before you
start dancing yeah these exercises are
based on some mistakes that i see people
doing often in minors sometimes the way
they approach the way they use their
arms to raise the partner is not the
best it's not the most beautiful
so i will make you aware of a few
details that you should be careful with
and after the warm up i will show you
four exercises that will help you
improve exactly that okay
so let's start with the warm up okay
warm up so let's start with our feet
together yeah make sure your feet are
touching and your legs are closed yeah
um straight posture relax the shoulders
relax the arms make sure that you are
looking straight in front of you to your
horizon and that your head is straight
yeah and just breathe deeply a few times
and feel the weight of your body on the
floor through your feet okay let it come
down
okay and we start with shoulder
rotations remember to make them slow and
big and remember to keep the arms
relaxed the whole time don't bend the
elbows when the shoulders go up yeah
keep the elbows relaxed okay
we do eight rotations let's go one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight okay now we do arm circles
yeah remember to keep your elbows
stretched the whole time yeah don't bend
the elbows keep the elbows always
straight
and remember to pass the hands behind
your back when you are in this position
when the with the arms open
so that your chest muscles open and
stretch okay and we do it again
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight okay very good now we stretch the
side of our torso to help us find the
vertical in our upper body okay
so we lift one arm
until it's completely straight pointing
up elbow is also straight
and the hand that is on the leg
goes down
down the leg until you can touch your
knee more or less yeah try to touch the
side of your knee so you have to bend
yeah and then you keep this stretch
for three seconds and then you use the
hand on top to pull yourself up again
straight
and then you lower the arm and you
repeat it to the other side okay
so we do it four times to each side
let's go
one lift the arm
go down
touch the knee
hold it
and up
and one to the other side
touch the knee
and hold it
and go up
two if yarn
go down your leg
hold the stretch
and up
and two
go down your leg touch the knee hold the
stretch
and up
three
go down
hold it
and up
and three
go down
hold it
and up
for the last one
go down touch the knee
hold the stretch
and up
and four
go down the leg
touch the knee
hold the stretch
and up
okay
great now we open the legs
we bend the knees a little bit
and we make sure that the hip is
straight yeah
then make a circle with your arms a
white circle and rotate the torso left
and right yeah now make sure that while
you rotate the torso your head and your
hip is always looking in front of you
don't move the hip like this keep it
straight yeah and make sure that you
don't move the arms alone because then
the exercise is not helping you at all
you have to move your back yeah you have
to move your back
from the middle okay the arms don't do
anything the arms just move together
with my upper body okay and we do it
eight times
twice to each side so 16 okay
let's go on
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight eight more one
two
three
four
[Music]
five
six
seven
and eight
okay now stretch the knees and for the
next exercise you will keep the knees
stretched the whole time yeah so put
your hands behind your uh head here and
then just bend down
yeah keeping the knees stretched until
your back is parallel with the floor
yeah then from here keep going down yeah
as much as you can and then bounce three
times bounce bounce bounce make sure
that your knees are straight yeah
and then starting from the head
you go up again until you are straight
okay and we repeat this eight times okay
so let's go
one
go down
[Music]
then
bounce bounce bounce
and go up
two go down
bounce bounce bounce
and go
three go down
bounce bounce bounce
and go up
or go down slowly control
bounce bounce bounce
and go up control
yeah don't move too fast five
go down
bounce bounce bounce and go up
six
go down slowly
bounce bounce bounce
and go up
seven go down
bounce pass bounce very relaxed and go
up and the last one eight
go down slowly
and bounce bounce bounce
and go up okay
now lower the arms but keep the legs uh
open like this and then he's stretched
because now you will grab your hips and
we will do circles with the hip yeah so
you start with the hip behind
and then you move the hip to the side
making sure that your knees stay
stretched and the heels on the on the
ground yeah and then move the hip
forward and then move it to the other
side and then
again to the
first position yeah
make sure that you are not doing this
yeah that you are not moving the upper
torso
the head is always on the same position
and at least the hip there is moving
okay
because many times people get confused
and start doing this okay so it's not
this it's this
it's a hip okay so we do it eight times
to one side anytime to the other side
let's go
one
two
three make it as big as you can yeah
four
five
six
mix straight all the time seven
and the last one eight
and then to the other side
one
two
three make it as big as you can
four
five
six keep your knees straight
seven
and
eight
okay
now we
put our feet together again
you can keep your hands on your hips
yeah
and then we bend the knees and we bounce
three times one two three then we
stretch the knees we go a little bit
forward and we go on the toes now make
sure that your feet stay closed and that
they don't open like this yeah this is
bad
so like this hold it for three seconds
make sure that your core is tight and
that you are looking forward to the
horizon yeah and then you go down
control yeah many people go down very
fast like this this is bad this is
dangerous so just go down slowly slowly
okay
and we'll do it eight times so let's go
go down bend the knees and then bounce
bounce bounce stretch the knees go up
hold it
and go down slowly two
underneath bounce bounce bounce
go up
hold it
and down three bend the knees bounce
bounce bounce
go up
hold it
and go down four go down bounce bounce
bounce go up
hold it keep your core tight
and down five go down bounce bounce
bounce go up
hold it keep the feet close
and down
six
go down bounce bounce bounce
then go up
hold it
and down
seven
bounce bounce bounce
go up
hold it
keep the feet close
and down and the last one eight bounce
bounce bounce
go up
hold it
and go down okay
and the last exercise relax the legs a
little bit
because now we will stretch our calf
muscles yeah so i show you from the
profile feet together like before hands
on the hips if you want and then
move one foot behind
yeah make sure that you don't open the
foot to the side it has to be directly
behind you okay from here directly
behind open it quite a lot
and then make sure that the heel is on
the floor and then the leg is straight
yeah the knee is stretched and then bend
the knee that is forward
slowly
until you feel a nice stretch on your
back calf yeah and let's just hold this
position for 25 seconds so let's count
to 25 slowly
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
and five okay and now stretch the front
knee so that you get up to the stretch
gently yeah
and we do it to the other side if you
have problems keeping the balance here
you can put one hand on the wall just
the fingers don't lean on the wall just
just put the fingers just touch the wall
that's enough okay
so let's go to the other side
move the other foot behind you make sure
the heel is on the floor
and then the knee is completely
stretched and then bend the front knee
until you feel a nice stretch on the
calf
and let's hold this position for 25
seconds 1
9 ten
one
[Music]
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
and five and now stretch the front knee
slowly so that you get out of the
stretch gently okay
so that's it
let's go to the first exercise okay the
first exercise will help you improve
your basic posture especially your torso
your rib cage yeah i will show you in
three quarters so that it's easier for
you to see what's going on
so first you cross the fingers of your
hands like this in front of you
then you turn your hands like this until
the palms are facing down to the floor
yeah
and then you stretch the elbows until
your arms are completely straight okay
then slowly you move your hands above
your head
like this yeah
this part of the exercise will help you
find the right position with your weight
a little bit forward because if you keep
the weight on above your heels and you
move the arms like this
you will fall back yeah and this is
wrong so
when you raise the arms
your body automatically goes a little
bit forward yeah and that's the posture
that you need for tangle okay
then when you are here imagine that you
can push the ceiling with your hands
yeah you can touch the ceiling with your
hands and you want to push the ceiling
up so you push you push up so your
elbows will become even more straight
yeah remember to keep the shoulders down
push push push and then this pushing
what it does
is that it raises your rib cage yeah
your ribcage goes up and forward away
from the hip yeah
and then after the pushing you let go of
the hands you move the arms slowly down
but you keep the tension on the position
of the torso of the ribcage yeah
the point of the exercise is that you
are using your arms
to help you find the right angle forward
and the right position for the ribcage
the arms
help the ribcage go up here when you are
pushing yeah
and then
the point is to let go of the arms when
you don't need them anymore
but keep the position that you found
by moving the arms for your torso yeah
and that's the position you need for
tango okay
so let's do this exercise together four
times slowly okay so first you cross the
fingers you turn the hands down
until the palms are facing the floor
then you stretch the elbows yeah and
then you move the hands
above your head
yeah and here you will see how the
weight of your body goes towards the
front of your feet okay then you push up
with your hands push push push push this
is lifting your ribcage
push push push and then let go
but keep the tension and the position of
the upper body yeah
relax the shoulders but feel how your
chest stays up
let's do it one more time close the
fingers turn the hands down
stretch the elbows
move the hands above your head
and then push this is the main part of
the exercise push push push push push
push as much as you can then let go
lower the arms
but keep the torso where it is
okay
let's do one more time
fingers crossed
turn
the palms down
stretch the elbows
move the arms up above your head
your weight is on the front of the feet
then push with your hands up push push
push push push push push
and then let go
and
keep the torso where it is yeah
if now you would embrace your partner
your position your posture and the
tension of your body would be exactly
the right one okay
so do this exercise a few times and you
will feel how your posture improves
okay let's go to the next exercise okay
for this exercise you will need a wall
which will simulate your partner and
this exercise will help you approach
and position yourself in front of the
partner in the right way
and this has to do with the first
mistake that i see some people doing in
the middle
and what they do is that when they walk
towards the partner they already have
the hands and the arms kind of halfway
towards the position of the embrace they
walk to the partner with the hands a bit
in front of them
and i would recommend that you don't do
that
uh i would recommend that instead you
walk towards the partner with your hands
down and the arms in rest position yeah
like this and at first you think of your
chest yeah to place your chest and then
you think of the arms yeah
why because
if you walk with the hands a little bit
up and in front of you this projects a
lack of confidence it projects
insecurity because this is what we do
when we don't feel very secure the other
hands look a bit like a barrier between
you and the partner you have the hands
in front of you and if you do it very
extreme yeah
it just looks wrong yeah you look a bit
like a zombie or like a sleepwalker
but if you walk with the arms down this
projects confidence because
you don't need any protection any
barrier with your hands in front of you
before you make contact with your
partner okay
and even if you dance in open embrace so
you don't need to make contact even in
that case i would still recommend that
you walk towards the partner with the
arms down
and that then you place
your chest at the right distance yeah
and you place it as if you were going to
make contact although you don't because
it's all open embrace but you place it
as if you were going to make contact and
then you
move the arms
to the embrace okay so
walk to the partner chest first arms
second not arms first second okay
so the exercise is to help you with this
yeah and it it looks like this you stand
in front of the wall with your um feet
together yeah and a little bit away from
the wall yeah i would use one width of a
foot like this yeah
and then the exercise is
to remember the
exercise we did before yeah to place
your chest up and forward and then to
tilt your weight forward until your
torso makes contact with the chest with
the wall now don't make contact with the
wall with your chest because if you use
your chest
this will happen
yeah it's very uncomfortable you don't
have space for your head your hip goes
back yeah so instead you have to touch
the wall with the ribs below the chest
yeah the ribs where his heart here the
middle of your torso below the chest
that's the part that touches the wall
yeah
more or less where the sternum ends yeah
here
yeah because if you use this point then
you have space for your head no problem
your hip is also
straight yeah
and
then you
go again to the first position yeah so
you are here then you touch the wall
with the ribs and then you go away and
then you repeat this and this
and this and this and this is what you
should do
once you walk towards the partner before
you move the arms
this is what you do
okay
and we will do it um
twice eight times okay so let's do it
together place yourself in front of the
wall relax the arms relax the neck
shoulders down
and then keep your torso straight
and
move towards the wall and touch it with
your ribs below the chest
one
and go away
two
and go
three i go
four
go
five
and
six
five
times
eight
yeah make sure that you are looking in
front of you all the time if you need to
do this
then it's wrong yeah you are touching
the wall two up yeah touch it a bit
lower okay let's do it eight more times
one
go
two
go three
go
four
five
go that's the wall with the ribs huh
six
go
seven
eight
and go
okay
so first you will do this and then you
would use the arms to raise your partner
and this is what the next exercise is
about about the arms okay
so let's go to the next exercise okay
this exercise will help you improve the
way you move your arms when you're
already in front of your partner and you
want to embrace them
because the mistake that i see many
people doing is that when they are
already in front of their partners and
they want to embrace them they move
their hands from the resting position to
the embrace position in a straight line
like this from here to here or from here
to here directly in a straight line and
it doesn't look so good because when you
embrace your partner you want to first
of all open the arms yeah because you
want to create the impression of space
and you want to wrap your arms around
your partner so for that you need a
curve it needs to be a curve and not a
straight line you are not like this
so for that you need to use the
shoulders and the elbows yeah
and the exercise has two variations one
is more for the woman the other is more
for the man but i recommend you to do
both yeah
so on the first one for the woman
we open the arms a little bit yeah to
the sides
and then when they are here we relax the
elbows a lot and we use the elbows to
move the hands in a circle like this
okay
the circles are in the vertical plane
you see the circles are
are aligned to this plane to the
vertical okay
and this helps you
to
get the feeling of a curve of using your
elbows to move your hands in a curve
when you embrace the partner yeah
okay like this especially for the woman
this is more for the woman
okay so
let's
do circles with the elbows yeah like
this let's do them four times eight okay
so open the arms
and then relax the elbows
and let's just do these circles
and one
two three four five six seven eight one
two three four five
six seven eight okay make sure that you
don't take shortcuts yeah that you don't
move your hands in some kind of straight
line somewhere you have to relax the
elbows and
make sure that the hand is doing the
full circle okay
now the version for the man is very
similar but instead of using the
vertical plane we use the horizontal
plane yeah so i open my arms and then i
move the hands in front of me and then
towards my chest so the circles look
like this yeah it's very similar
but the circle now is aligned on the
horizontal plane and not so much in the
vertical plane and this is because the
man embraces more from the middle yeah
especially with the right hand
and is more about wrapping
in this way
yeah on the horizontal
instead of the woman who usually she
goes to the shoulder or the back and
it's more this is more than vertical
yeah vertical
horizontal so let's do the circles in
the horizontal plane now again four
times eight okay so open the arms and
then remember move the hands towards
your chest and continue with the circle
okay and
one
two three four five six seven eight one
two three four five six seven eight
one two three four
five six seven eight okay
the circle works like this not like this
because this is more like swimming no
it's embracing it's to the inside okay
good the same for the woman
not like this yeah
but like this because you want to wrap
your arms around the partner okay so
when you are in front of the corner and
you want to embrace remember the circle
yeah because this will help you move
your hands in a very beautiful curve
yeah to the embrace
like this and not in a straight line
okay
good let's go for the last exercise okay
in this last exercise we will put all
the areas together in one okay
again we will do two versions one for
the woman one for the man but i
recommend you all to do both versions
okay and i will show you from the front
but then i will show you from behind
because in this exercise our arms are
not moving symmetrically anymore one arm
is moving different from the other and
then we need to have the same right and
the same left okay but in any case i
show you from the front now
and what i do is first of all i start
with the first exercise so i close my
hands my fingers i turn the hands
stretch the elbows and go up like this
okay this is so that my chest will be
properly placed then i let go of the
arms but remember to keep the position
of the torso
and then here starts the second part of
the exercise i open my arms and then i
use the elbows to make a curve yeah
and reach the position of the embrace
for the walk yeah so
like this yeah
shoulders and elbows and then when i'm
here i let go of the embrace when you
have finished the dance and you want to
let go of the embrace you don't just
drop the arms like this
you
rewind the movement like this yeah so
embrace
and let go
yeah you do the movement the same
movement in reverse embrace let go
embrace a little okay and we do it twice
eight times okay so now i show you from
behind
and we do it together
first
let's do the first exercise you close
the fingers you turn the hands down
stretch the elbows
and then
put your hands above your head and push
the ceiling push with the hands up yeah
push push push
and you feel that your rib cage is
completely up and forward and then let
go of the arms
but keep the position of the torso okay
and then from this position
let's do it together
twice eight times using the shoulders
and the elbows
for to move our hands in a curve to
their breaks and then we rewind the
movement to let go okay let's go
one
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight eight more
one
and
two
three
and four
and
five
six
and
seven
eight
okay remember that the most important
thing is to use the elbows
to move your hands in a curve
huh okay now we do the version for the
man it's the same thing
we cross the fingers we turn the hands
we stretch the elbows
we go up like this then we push yeah
this is so that we place our rib cage in
the right position we let go of the arms
but we keep the chest in the
position that we found
and then we use the shoulders to open
our arms
and we do the embrace of the man so you
use the elbows to move your hands in a
circle
okay
like this and then from here
we rewind the movement yeah you don't
drop the arms when you finish dancing
you rewind the movement to go to this
position yes so embrace
and let go
embrace and let go okay so now i do it
from behind
so first exercise cross the fingers
turn the hands stretch the elbows
and put the hands above
your head
and then push up
push up until you feel your rib cage
completely up and forward okay
then let go of the arms but keep the
chest and the ribcage where it is
and then from here
open the arms a little bit and use the
elbows
to move your hands in a circle
and then rewind the movement let go and
press position again let's do it twice
eight times ah
one
seven
and
eight
eight more
one
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
five
seven
and
eight
and yeah
now that we are doing it as an exercise
you can exaggerate you can exaggerate
yeah you can open your arms completely
and then use the elbows to make a wide
circle the same when you let go of the
embrace use the elbows to open your arms
wide and then
put them down lower them yeah exactly
because then in the melody you can
always reduce it but even if you do it
small yeah for example if the melon is
very full
um you will always keep the curve even
if the movement is
small you will always have a curve and
this will always look very beautiful
okay so next time you go dancing
remember the elbows remember the circles
yeah and use them because your embrace
will look very beautiful okay so thank
you very much for watching practice a
lot
and i will see you in the next video bye